JULIA FERRAIOLI: Welcome to
the Google I/O session on
Integrating Google+ into Your
Mobile Applications.
My name is Julia Ferraioli.
I am a developer advocate
working
on the Google+ platform.
Most of my time is spent making
sure that developers
like you have what
you need to be
successful with our platform.
Before we get started, I'd
like to get a quick poll.
Who here is working on a mobile
app or has built one?
Fantastic.
I think this is the right
room, the right
session for us today.
It's clear that we have some
really, really passionate
mobile developers here.
We've actually got another
one joining us today.
I'd like to introduce
Francis Ma.
FRANCIS MA: Thank you, Julia.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Francis Ma, and I'm
the product manager leading
our mobile developer efforts
for the Google+ platform.
It's a lot of fun here meeting
you guys face to face.
You guys having a good time?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FRANCIS MA: Excellent, and today
we have some exciting
stuff to share with you.
Now, just before we go there, I
want to first take a moment
to reflect on the reason
we're here and to share
our vision with you.
It was exactly a year ago when
we launched Google+ with two
goals in mind.
First, it was to build a social
destination to bring
the richness of real-life
sharing to the Web.
And second, it was to build a
platform that serves as the
social spine across all of
Google products to make our
services better with identity
and sharing.
And in the last 12 months,
we have built an engaging
community of over 150 million
monthly active users who come
back to Google to engage one
another or participate in
conversations.
So now we're taking this next
step to extend the platform to
mobile developers with the
vision of helping you create
more engaging social experiences
and to connect
with more users.
Now, the reason we have chosen
to treat mobile as a
first-class citizen--
because we believe, and as many
of you probably also do,
is that mobile is the future.
Let's take a look at some
of the numbers.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So if you've
been to any of the other
mobile sessions at Google I/O
this year, you may have seen
some of these numbers.
But just to refresh, we have
over 100 million smart devices
active in the United
States today and
over 950 million globally.
But sometimes, that's kind of
hard to keep in my head--
I don't really know what 950
million devices looks like.
So I'm just going to put this
picture of a pink baby up on
the screen.
FRANCIS MA: What's that?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So for every
child born per minute, there
are three smart devices
being activated.
So to handle that, the kid would
have to use two hands
and maybe a foot--
something like that.
FRANCIS MA: Wow, must
be expensive
if you've got triplets.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Better
start planning now.
But what does this mean
in terms of Google+?
FRANCIS MA: So this exciting
growth on mobile, we're seeing
that too on Google+.
Today, more users access Google+
from a mobile device
than they do from a
desktop computer.
And with this incredible
momentum, we're very excited
to announce the Google+ platform
for mobile and our
very first release in developer
preview, Google+
SDKs for iOS and for Android
coming soon.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So today, we
really could use more than the
45 minutes we have.
But we're going to use the
time we have to cover the
overview of the platform, as
well as how what we're
offering comprises a complete
mobile story, including
meaningful identity, lightweight
social actions,
and the ability to write moments
from within your app.
We'll be telling this all
through an app that we've
built just for this session
at Google I/O.
We're going to leave about 15
minutes at the end for Q&A. So
please save your questions
till then.
Or come see us at the Sandbox
office hours or on Google+.
So Google Play services
is a broad--
let's just give a
broad overview
of Google Play services.
It's how integration with
Google+ will work on Android.
Google Play services will be an
extension of Google Play.
And it's designed to make OA and
web services easier from
your Android application.
Now, all Froyo up devices
will have Google
Play services installed.
And that means that 95% of
Android devices will be able
to take advantage of this.
Now, it handles the complexity
of identifying the user so
that you can focus on creating
a fantastic user experience
within your own application.
But what does it get you?
Well, Francis really loves
playing games.
And sometimes he's on a road
trip and he's had a really
great high score on one
of his favorite games.
And he wanted to share
it, maybe--
FRANCIS MA: Show it off.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: --show
it off a little bit.
But right at that moment,
he entered a tunnel.
Cell reception dropped
to nothing.
Ordinarily, the app would have
to handle these instances
where you lose connectivity.
But with Google Play services,
the app can still try
to share that out.
The call will be automatically
queued until
connectivity is regained.
So your app no longer has
to handle that sort of
complexity.
It also handles updates.
So that if you're picking up
an SDK that maybe has some
image resources or client
libraries to an API, if those
particular resources were
updated, you would have to
pick up a new version of the
SDK, incorporate it into your
app, test it, re-release,
et cetera.
Now, with Google Play services,
that update will be
handled within Google Play
services itself.
So you no longer have to go
through that process and pick
up new bits.
It decreases time for
you as developers.
So all you have to do is include
a thin client library
within your app.
And it decreases the app size
because you're no longer
including those images
or client libraries.
And you can keep the
size of it down.
That's beneficial
to your users.
FRANCIS MA: So it's really
exciting to give you this
sneak peek of the Google Play
services coming soon.
And to walk you through the
details of how you do this,
we're going to show you an
example app that Julia's built
called the hiking planner to
solve a little problem that we
had with our friends who are a
little bit less organized and
less motivated to come
hiking with us.
And so Julia's built this hiking
planner app to help
organize and to recommend apps
between our friends.
Now, one of the things that she
wants to do was first to
build a personalized
experience.
And in order for her to do
that, she needed to add a
sense of identity in the app.
Now, she knows that there are
hundreds of millions of users
with Google accounts using
services like Gmail, Android,
and YouTube.
And so instead of creating her
own login password and
reinventing the wheel, she's
decided to use the Google+ SDK
and plug in Sign in
with Google+.
So that she can focus on her app
and let Google handle the
authentication.
Now from the user perspective,
what they get is Sign in with
Google+ button.
With this, we handle user
authentication and app
authorization through OAuth 2.
Let's take a look at
how this works.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So who here
has used OAuth in your
applications?
Who here absolutely loved
that experience?
FRANCIS MA: We have one.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: OK.
So one of the great benefits of
using Sign in with Google+
in the SDK is that you can
abstract away those details of
implementing OAuth.
So the first thing that you'll
want to do in your Android
application is just make a
one-line change to your
manifest file updating
the permissions.
This allows you to make use of
the Android account manager
that Francis just showed.
So that if your user has
multiple accounts on the
device, they can choose which
one they want to use with your
application.
The next thing is you're going
to want that button, right?
You want to have your user
have some way to sign in.
So this button--
it's a predefined button that
allows you to have that nice
look and feel of Sign in with
Google+ within your app.
It's really quite simple.
After that, you're just going
to want to implement the
interface, the
ConnectionCallbacks, and the
OnConnectionFailedListener.
You're going to add
a few variables.
Here we have the progress
dialogue that lets us know
where we are in the
sign-in process.
If your user is in the middle
of signing in, this is what
will show that.
The PlusClient and the
ConnectionStatus.
In the onCreate method, we
simply want to initialize our
PlusClient.
And you'll notice that
here we're adding the
Plus Profile scope.
And this allows you to fetch
information from your user's
Google+ profile to create this
nice, personalized experience
within your app.
We're just going to initialize
the progress dialogue and then
go on to a few other methods.
You're just going to override
these life-cycle methods,
including onStart, onStop,
onConnected, and Disconnected.
In the onConnectionFailed
method, you're just going to
set the connection
status here.
So if authentication fails for
whatever reason, this is where
you'll get back that status.
So once the user sees the
button, they're probably going
to want to tap it, right?
That's my inclination when I
see a button in my apps.
So you're going to want to
configure the onClick listener.
Now, we're just going to pull
it out of the view here.
And if it's not connected,
we're going to start that
process of signing
the user in.
And all we have to do is start
the ResolutionForResult in the
connection status.
Now we're going to give
it a code here,
Request code for error.
And this will allow us to find
out the result on activity
result method.
Now, if this was a sign-in
action, you're going to be
able to see the response code.
And here, we're just going to
assume that the user's signed
in successfully.
They've selected their account,
they've accepted the
permissions of the app, and
everything is result A-OK.
Once we know that, we can go
ahead and connect the user
using the PlusClient object.
Now, obviously, you're probably
going to want to do
some error handling
in your own app.
But for the sake of screen
size here, we're going to
assume everything went well.
FRANCIS MA: So let's take a
look at a real demo of how
this works.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: OK.
FRANCIS MA: OK.
Switch over this screen.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So here we
have our Hike Planner app.
This is just a very simple app
to help us get involved in
more hikes with our
connections.
So here you see the Sign
in button here.
And we're just going to
go ahead and tap that.
It's going to pull up all
of the accounts that
I have on my phone.
I'm going to select the one
that I want to use.
It's going to connect.
We're operating over
Wi-Fi here, so OK.
FRANCIS MA: So you saw earlier
in the screenshot, the user
experience when they tap on
the Sign in with Google+
button is they see the account
user, what you just saw.
And it allows users to choose
the account they
want to sign in with.
And the next step after that
would've been the OAuth
consent dialog to prompt the
user, hey, this is the
permission we want from
you to integrate
with the Google+ APIs.
And from there, it goes
right back to the app.
Now, one of the things you may
have noticed is that the user
doesn't need to actually type
in their login and password.
And as many of you may already
be familiar with, the Android
account manager is that users
sign in to the phone.
So with that, they won't have to
retype in their credentials
every time.
And they get a single sign-on
experience for your app.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Now, one of the
great things about having
your users sign in with Google+
is the fact that it
makes calling APIs,
particularly the
Google+ APIs, a breeze.
So then you can go and do such
great things like get their
profile information and
personalize it with their name
and their profile picture.
And that, then, can give them a
really connected feeling to
your application.
FRANCIS MA: So now that we have
a sense of user identity
in the app, the next step is
to make it more engaging by
adding social interactions.
Now, as I described before, that
Julia wants to make this
app to one, help our
friends organize
going on hiking trips.
But we also wanted a way to let
our friends recommend or
endorse particular hikes
that we like.
So she's chosen to add
the +1 button.
Now, as many of you may be
familiar with the +1 button--
it's a way to let your users
publicly endorse or recommend
any contents with a URL
associated with it.
Now, in this particular
example that
I've just put up--
and something that you can do
for your apps, as well--
is to point the +1 button to the
Google Play store URL so
that your users can
+1 your app.
So you can imagine that this is
really closing the loop of
when new users come on to the
Google Play store, they can
see social annotations as
a result of people they
know who have +1'd.
So here I've zoomed up the
text that says you
and Julia +1'd this.
So let's say if our friend
Jennifer comes on to the
store, she might say, oh, hey,
look, this is pretty
interesting.
I may have not heard about
this app before, but my
friends recommend it.
So let me try it out.
So with that, you can also,
of course, integrate
that into your app.
Let's take a look on
how to do this.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So when we were
trying to figure out what
part of our app would benefit
the most from the +1 button,
we thought, what a great way
to recommend the individual
hikes than to put a +1 button
on the hike itself.
So we decided to put it into
the individual hike view.
So you're just going to
add it to the layout.
Here again, it's already
defined for you.
The look and feel is there.
You'll notice some standard
Android layout elements.
And at the bottom, you
see the plus:size.
Now, just like on the
web, the +1 button
comes in various sizes.
You can have a small one, a
medium one, a large one.
And you can set those
attributes
directly in the XML file.
You can also do this
programmatically, as well.
In your onCreate function,
you'll simply pull it out of
the layout, initialize
it with a URL.
In this case, we're going to
target the URL to the Point
Reyes hike that we have.
Now, while we're pointing at
an HTML file that has some
information, some nice
schema.org markup on it, as
well as a picture description,
et cetera, you can also +1
other types of content, such
as pictures, videos, music.
All that matters is
that it have a
publicly accessible URL.
So you can include
this in various
points within your app.
FRANCIS MA: And so +1 is a
great way for people to
recommend content that has
a URL associated with it.
But sometimes on mobile, you may
have content that's stored
on your device but not have
a URL associated with it.
For example, I like to take
pictures and videos that are
stored on my phone.
And there isn't really
a way to +1 that.
Or sometimes, there's content
that I would like my users to
share more directly to Google+
without first having to +1 it.
So with that, you can
use the Share plugin
to share into Google+.
With the Share plugin, we
provide a dialogue through our
SDK for you to open the
Share plugin for users
to share into Google+.
Now, for this particular dialog,
we provide a way for
users to select the circles that
they want to share to.
There is an option to attach
their location, so you can use
this as a form of checking in.
And they can also attach
specific media that's stored
on the device.
Now, what's interesting about
this is when they share it
from your app, we also put a
label attributing it to where
it came from in the
specific post when
it shows up on Google+.
So here, you see this label
from the Hike Planner that
I've shared from.
And it shows this is where
the post was created.
So when you share interesting
information on Google+ and as
users converse around that, it
also helps drive awareness to
your application.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So you may
have heard of intents on
Android, specifically
share intents.
The recently released
ShareCompat support package
for Android made this even
easier and also supports the
attribution that Francis
was showing you.
So the first thing--
we're just going to create
a really simple intent.
And this is just to get our
friends up and excited about a
hike and to prompt them to come
join because it's really
a good time.
So we're going to use the
ShareCompat support package.
The Intent Builder will help
us construct this intent.
Now here, we're just going
to set some text.
Hey, I'm going on a hike.
Who wants to join?
Once we get the intent and start
it, it'll open up that
Google+ dialogue that
allows you to modify
it and select circles.
But you can also really easily
share links in your intent as
well, simply by adding in the
link within the set text part.
You're just going to append it
onto the end of your text.
Now, what will happen
is that it will go.
And it will look at that link
and draw it out into a nice
preview in the post.
So here we are pulling
out a title,
some text, and a picture.
And that's what will be attached
within your post.
But one of the great ways to
spark these really engaging
conversations on Google+
is by attaching media.
And we're just going to modify
that same intent to do that.
We're going to add in setStream
and setType.
And you're just going to set
the target to the data that
you want to share.
So say you have an app that
can share photos.
What you'll do is once you get
the result of that camera
action, you'll set the data
there and tell us what type of
media you're sharing.
And that's all that's to
it to share media.
But your user has already
signed in with Google+.
So why not make that even easier
for them by opening up
the Google+ dialogue directly?
You can do that with the
setPackage part here.
So you simply specify which
application you want to handle
this share intent, and it will
automatically open that up.
FRANCIS MA: So let's take
a look with a demo.
[INAUDIBLE].
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
So here we go.
We've got our Plan and
Share section here.
It's going to organize
with my circle.
So let's see how that
looks here.
OK, so I'm trying to
corral my friends.
I'm going to say, let's
go on a hike.
You know what?
It might be a really crowded
hike if I just add everybody.
So let's just do this with--
let's search for somebody.
Let's search for Francis.
There we go, and that's OK.
You know what?
I'm going to choose--
location, we're actually
going to go on a
hike someplace else.
So let's not attach location
to this post.
And once I send that off,
it will be sent to--
my post has been shared.
And it'll appear in
Francis's stream.
FRANCIS MA: So why don't
we [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Excellent.
FRANCIS MA: Let's
check that out.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So here we
have the Point Reyes hike.
We've got it centered around
where it is on the map.
And up here you can
see the +1 button.
Let's go ahead and +1 that.
So here you see it's got, you
publicly +1'd this as Julia
Ferraioli and attribution
to the Hike Planner app.
FRANCIS MA: And just like the
desktop +1 button, the user
has the option to share
after they +1 as well.
So now, while sharing to Google+
is great because it
lets people comment
on it right away
and all your circles--
whoever it might be--
can see it and interact around
that immediately.
But sometimes, there are little
moments in life where
you just want to remember but
not necessarily share it right
then and there, or have it
shared automatically.
So for example, Julia wants
to remember specific
moments from her hikes.
And she likes to use
Instant Upload.
Because it's a great way for her
to capture photos and have
it uploaded to the cloud
automatically into her private
album, which then she can
share at a later time.
But she wants to do that not
just with photos, with other
things as well.
And as a developer, she wants
the ability to hook this
functionality into her app.
So with that, she's chosen
to use Google+ history.
So Google+ history is a new
feature that we've recently
announced in Developer Preview
that lets your app write
moments into Google+ and into
the user's private history and
allow them to share that
at a later time.
Now, on Android with Google
Play services, we have a
special intent for you to write
moments from your app.
So when these moments are
recorded into the user's
history, they can go back onto
Google+ afterwards at a later
time to then optionally share
to their circles.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So how do you
construct this moment within
your Android app?
Well, it's quite
straightforward.
You're just going to construct
an intent with some JSON.
So for our app, we wanted to add
the ability to check in to
maybe a particular hike--
maybe the start,
maybe the end.
Hopefully they're the same
place, maybe not.
So we're going to construct
in this
example a check-in moment.
The first thing that we're going
to do is create a JSON
object for our place, where
we're going to check in.
We're going to check in to
Point Reyes right here.
And we're going to put that
in the URL for the place.
Next, we're going to construct
the overall moment.
And we're going to give it the
type of check-in activity.
And then we're simply going to
put the place in the target of
that moment.
The next thing that we want to
do is actually go ahead and
construct that intent.
And we're simply going to create
a Write Moment intent
here and put the stringified
JSON in the
payload of that moment.
Now once we send it off,
it's sent privately
to the user's history.
So should we take a
look at our app?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah,
let's do a demo.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So Francis
and I went on a hike.
We went on a hike out behind
the Google campus where
there's actually a nice trail.
It was really strenuous.
FRANCIS MA: That was a nice
afternoon exercise.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So we
coordinated using Share.
We took some pictures
and video.
We checked in along the way--
all written to our history
using moments.
So on Android, here we
have a few options
to create our moments.
We can check in, and you
can see it was saved.
If you were going to take a
photo, you could then write
that into the user's history,
as well as for videos.
But let's take a look at
the end result here.
FRANCIS MA: So one of the things
that Julia mentioned
earlier about Google Play
services is that it also
remembers or queues us up
on the client side.
So even though if you have
temporary connectivity loss,
we automatically retry
that for you.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So if I were on
Mount Everest and I didn't
have cell service, I could still
brag about it later?
FRANCIS MA: You can still
brag about it later.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Cool.
FRANCIS MA: So here's this
example of my history here.
And so we went on the hike the
other day-- took an afternoon
hike during work.
And we checked in, recorded
some of this here.
So this was from the +1 earlier
that we showed you
from the hiking planner app.
And we've also captured video.
This is really awesome,
Oscar-winning stuff here.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: We did
some slow mo here.
FRANCIS MA: And so through the
history, I can then now choose
which particular moments I want
to share with my circles.
So let's take a look at what
happens when I hover over this
moment and share it.
Now, because we snuck out during
the day, I don't want
to share to all my circles.
I want to share it to
colleagues, but not my boss.
I don't want to tell him.
All right, and there it is.
It is shared.
I want to go back to the stream,
and there it is.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Francis, maybe
you want to share the
check-in so they actually
know where we went.
FRANCIS MA: I don't
know if I want to
reveal that to my boss.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: OK.
FRANCIS MA: All right.
[INAUDIBLE].
So we've been spending the past
couple minutes talking
about Android.
But I did mention there was an
iOS Google+ SDK as well.
So we're going to take a quick
peek at what that's about.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So we actually
developed the same
app for iOS as well.
Would you like to
switch the--?
So as a word of caution, I am
not in any way a designer.
So this is bare bones
Hike Planner app.
So here we have the
Sign In button.
I'm just going to go
ahead and sign in.
Now, because I have the Google+
app installed on my
phone and signed into it, it's
actually going to use that for
my identity.
FRANCIS MA: Well, the Wi-Fi's a
little bit funky here today.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: We are
operating on Wi-Fi here.
FRANCIS MA: So what happens is
very similar to the Android
side, where, as Julia mentioned,
if the user-- if
you have the Google+ app
installed and your user's
already signed into that, we use
the Google+ app to handle
the app authorization so that
the user won't have to
re-enter their login
and password again.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So let's take
a look at Share on iOS.
So here, we have the same
Organize with my circles here,
and it's simply going to open
up the Share box with that
text pre-populated
like on Android.
And I can add who
I want to share.
And it's going to show my
connections, my circles.
And I can search as well.
And then, of course, when you
finish or cancel, it'll go
right back to your
application.
FRANCIS MA: And with that, you
can also attach a location
with your post through the
iOS Share plugin as well.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So let's take
a look at how you would go
about doing this on iOS.
So the first thing, just like
in your Android app, you're
going to create and configure
your Sign in
with Google+ button.
Now, all of this is included
in our SDK.
So once you add it to the view
that you want to handle sign
in, you're simply going to
set a few things here.
You're going to set the
delegate to your view
controller that you
want to handle it.
And then you're going to tell
us what your client ID is.
Now, who here has seen the
Google APIs console this I/O?
OK, so you will get your client
ID by going to the
Google APIs console and
creating a project.
Then you're going to tell us
what sorts of scopes that you
want in your Sign in button.
Now here, we're going to add the
plus.me scope, but you can
also add other types
of scopes as well.
And this could be if you want to
write moments, it'll be the
write moments scope.
Or if you want to add other
Google services scopes here,
you could do that as well.
And then you're simply going
to set the appDelegate
delegate to the Sign
in button.
Now, in your view controller,
you're going to add the sign
in delegate here.
And this simply tells you what
happened when your user
completed authorization.
And here, once you implement
this, you can do other things
like populate the view, maybe
make an API call.
And this is where you would
find out that result.
In your apps delegate, you're
going to forward declare the
class and simply declare
this property
for the Sign in button.
And you're going to want
to handle the result of
authentication in your
app delegate as well.
So whereas if you have the
Google+ app installed, it will
go to the app.
It may also--
if you don't, if your user does
not have it installed, it
will default to the web.
And this is how you would
handle that result.
Now, sharing on iOS
is very easy.
All you're going to do is first
create the share object.
You're going to initialize it
with your client ID and set
its delegate.
And then, you're just going to
simply tell us what you want
to share and open
the share box.
Here, we're just going to do
the let's go on a hike.
We're going to actually share
where we want to go.
And then we're going
to open it.
Now, both of these properties
are optional.
So you could simply open the
share box up with nothing
there, or you can make it
as rich as you want.
When you're thinking about
writing moments on iOS, it's
actually going to look a lot
like it does on Android.
You're just going to
construct the JSON
object and send it off.
So here, we're going to
construct the place, and this
is simply an item scope.
These are some open source
libraries that
come with the SDK.
We're going to set the
place to our hike.
And then we're going to create
the moment with our hike there
in the target.
You'll then construct the query
and simply send it off
through the Google+ service.
So it's your turn to really go
out and empower your users to
start making moments
within your app.
Allow them to really engage with
each other and construct
these moments.
Now, you can get started by
visiting our mobile-centric
documentation here on our site,
as well as engage with
us on our Google+
developers page.
We'll be posting the session
slides a little bit
later at this URL.
But you can also get to it on
the Google I/O session page.
We'll also be posting the code
for both of these applications
a little bit later, so
stay tuned for that.
So thanks so much for
coming today.
We're going to put our contact
information up on the slides
while we take some questions.
And we may have something for
people who ask questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the presentation.
I have a couple of questions.
So you mentioned that we have
to have a Sign in button.
Is it necessary for them
to click Sign in?
Or can they just click on +1 and
you would automatically--
if they're not signed in, you
would take care of it?
FRANCIS MA: So on the Android
side, we do help the user sign
in through the +1 button so
that they don't have to
explicitly click Sign in.
Also to note that we do provide
the standard button
asset of Sign in with Google+.
But we also give you the option
to hooking it into your
app in a more appropriate
flow as well.
So that's another option.
AUDIENCE: And we can use
our own custom +1
buttons and all also?
Do we have to use--
because the app may
not support.
There's not much space.
FRANCIS MA: We do have standard
branding guidelines
around how the +1 button
can be used.
And you can reference that in
our developer documentations.
AUDIENCE: OK, and one
last question.
Once you're signed in, are we
supposed to save some kind of
credentials so that they
don't have to sign
in again and again?
FRANCIS MA: So the end result
of using the sign in is you
get the OAuth token.
And so you can use that much
like you would if you had
manually integrated
OAuth 2 yourself.
You can use that token to then
call the APIs with it.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Thank you.
FRANCIS MA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'm not sure if this is the
right place to ask, but can I
post on behalf of
another user?
For instance, let's say someone
registers for a marathon.
And we're doing the timing
of the marathon.
And we know they finished, and
they've authorized us to post
to their profile their time.
Is that supported?
I do that with Facebook
and Twitter.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So that's an
excellent use case for moments
is the ability to post to a
user's private history from
your app automatically.
Then they can go and share that
out to their circles, in
case it's an embarrassing
time or what have you.
That would be me.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
So they can authorize us to
post to their history?
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
That's correct.
In the Sign in button, you would
simply add the scope,
the write moment scope.
And then you would be able
to construct that moment.
And I'm trying to think what a
time would be-- it might be
just a generic object, create
activity item that you could
then sent to their Google+
private history.
AUDIENCE: I'll try that.
And also another question is,
I see this Post to history.
Does that mean that now
with Google+ app I can
post without any--
like right now, it seems like
it fails if I try to post
without network connectivity.
Is the Google+ app going to
support offline mode then?
Or how do I do that?
FRANCIS MA: It will be the
Google Play services that we
showed much earlier on
in the presentation.
So just to recap that, Google
Play services is a service
that is provisioned through
Google Play.
And it lives on the client
side of the device.
So because you're interacting
with this client-side service,
we handle the offline
queuing for you.
So the answer for specifically
writing moments--
yes, we provide an intent
on Android that you
can write to it.
And we also handle the offline
retries for you.
AUDIENCE: But I guess I'm
asking, the Google+ app, by
default, will it support
this too?
Like the one that comes with--
when you install Google+,
I try to post,
and I'm in the subway.
And it just fails.
FRANCIS MA: I see.
I'm sorry, I misunderstood
the question.
The Google+ app currently
does not have the retry.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Will you be exposing
support for integrating with
the new Google+ event stuff?
Because that would be awesome.
Instead of making a post, come
join me, start an event with a
TBD location.
And then figure all that out.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right now
what is supported is
retrieving event information
through the RESTful API.
You do retrieve events through--
you can retrieve
events through the
RESTful API.
But as for creation, we have
nothing to say at this time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That works.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Francis.
This is Arthur from Flipboard.
I have a question about
the OAuth token.
Is that token associated with
my app or with Google Play?
FRANCIS MA: It's a token
associated with your app.
AUDIENCE: So we can use it on
the back end to make requests
about the user?
FRANCIS MA: That's right.
So with this Google Auth
service, this token is
associated with your app just
like it would be had you
manually integrated
OAuth 2 yourself.
Now for Android specifically,
this token is associated--
well, it's meant for a
client-side API call.
So in theory, you can pass
it to your server.
But at this time, we primarily
focus on having the client
speaking with the Google+
APIs directly.
AUDIENCE: And in practice?
We need to use it on the server
side because all of our
API calls are made
on the server.
FRANCIS MA: Absolutely.
That's something that we're
looking to improve on.
And so we can definitely talk
more about your specific use
case and how we can
address that.
AUDIENCE: So I have one
other question.
So we support YouTube and Google
Reader and a ton of
Google properties.
Can we go through the same
mechanism for getting
credentials for those
services?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
So one of the things that you
saw earlier was we give the
user an option to pass in
the various scopes.
Or we let the app pass in
whichever scopes it is that
they want to ask for.
So one option--
just throwing this out there--
is that you can ask for, let's
say, YouTube scopes
and also Google+
scopes at the same time.
So that user will only see
one consent screen.
And they can just grant
the access once, and
you're good to go.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
FRANCIS MA: Thanks, Arthur.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: You should
also come see us later for
stickers, those people who
have asked questions.
AUDIENCE: This is a little
more about privacy.
The data that [? we ?] retrieve
through the API,
especially on connect, what's
our right for storing it
offline on our services?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Can you be a
little bit more specific about
what you're talking about?
AUDIENCE: Let's say if we
retrieve a user's name, for
example, or their email address,
can we store that for
later use associated with
another account?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So we do have
standard terms of service that
cover these questions, even
with our web APIs.
So we do ask that you have a
privacy policy for your app
stating what you collect
and how you treat it.
AUDIENCE: Can a user--
or can my app go back and query
the user's history that
they put in so I could see
which-- for instance, like
with a badging application.
If I want to save their badges
as a moment, and I want to
show all badges that they've
earned, could I do that?
FRANCIS MA: We're currently--
for the history API, we're only
providing the ability to
write into the history.
And so currently the option
is just to write into it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: But that's
a great suggestion.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just to finish your example.
So you share the activity
of asking for a hike.
And let's say five people +1
that activity, and three
people commented asking
to move the date.
How would my application
find out about it?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: How would
your application
find out about it?
That's a great question.
You can retrieve activities
through the API.
AUDIENCE: But you have
to keep polling that.
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
That's correct.
Well, you could get the ID of
the activity and then poll for
that specific--
AUDIENCE: So [? this ?]
application will have
to keep track of--
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Correct.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: OK, so
you would want some--
I'd be happy to talk--
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's a
feedback, right?
If you engage something,
you want to know
what's coming back.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Right,
you would have to
poll for it, yes.
AUDIENCE: And so the second
question is, once you sign in,
the open auth is hidden from
you, but I assume that there
is an open auth talking
return back.
Is there any way to access
that talking directly?
Or is it exposed to the app
or it's completely hidden?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: It is
exposed to the app.
The great part about signing
into Google+ is that you can
simply use the object that
you get back for
authenticator calls.
AUDIENCE: And the client ID
which is used to do the open
auth, essentially the
application doesn't have to
store the private
key, or does it?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So when you
create the client ID, you give
some information.
And we can go over that later.
I can show you what that flow
looks like that would identify
your application.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right.
Thanks.
FRANCIS MA: Thank you.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: We had
a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Are your services
going to expose other write
actions for Google+, like
commenting on existing posts?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: So actually,
comment activity is one of the
moments that you can write--
AUDIENCE: To the history.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: To the user's
history, correct.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I noticed there is attribution
for +1's.
But on the web, I didn't see any
attribution for moments.
Is that coming or
not supported?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: There are
attribution for moments.
AUDIENCE: Oh, there are?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah, that's
something that we're actively
looking into.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that you
had the ability to add JSON
and you construct whole
JSON objects and send
the intent with that.
I was wondering if there's any
particular reason why lot of
that stuff can't just be
added to the intent
itself, just as extras--
as would have been
done in the past.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: It
actually was.
We stringified it first.
It was just to make the
construction just a little bit
more clear.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Any
other questions?
FRANCIS MA: We have one more.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
So currently the session is
active for one hour, right?
The [? document which ?]
is returned.
Auto renewal--
does application have
to do it explicitly?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: You can
actually try to sign in.
And then I believe it just--
AUDIENCE: Just auto
renews itself.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JULIA FERRAIOLI: Your user
shouldn't have to grant
permissions again.
AUDIENCE: Again?
JULIA FERRAIOLI: No.
They won't.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, thanks.
JULIA FERRAIOLI: You're just
aiming for two stickers,
aren't you?
Thanks so much.
FRANCIS MA: Thank
you very much.